I think we can have an intelligent
conversation about drug policy and the
degree to which it may or may not be
achieving the ends we hope it would
achieve I will say one thing that has
been dismaying about the Obama
administration is the Obama
administration's approach to drug policy
is simply to announce that across the
country it is going to stop enforcing
certain drug laws now that may or may
not be a good policy idea but I would
suggest that should concern anyone it
should even concern libertarians who
support that policy outcome because the
idea that the president simply says
criminal laws that are on the books
we're going to ignore that is a very
dangerous precedent for the 43
presidents who preceded President Obama
the way you dealt with if you disagreed
with the particular laws you go to
Congress and you try to work with
Congress and drug policy is a great
example where you can find Republicans
and Democrats on both sides of the aisle
who can come together and agree we may
need to make some reforms to our drug
laws to make them work better to make
them make more sense but anyone who is
concerned about liberty should be
concerned about the notion that this
president over and over again has
asserted the the right to pick and
choose what laws to follow that is
fundamentally dangerous to the liberty
of the people you know the concept of
rule of law doesn't just mean you've got
lots of laws just about every society
has laws and indeed dictatorships
typically suffer from an abundance of
laws what rule of law means is that
we're a nation of laws not of men that
no man is above the law especially not
the president and so I think most
disturbingly watching President Obama's
approach to drug laws is that he hasn't
tried to start a discussion a dialogue
about changing the laws he simply
decreed he's not going to enforce laws
he doesn't agree with that out of
concern everyone who loves Liberty the
single biggest lie in politics is the
lie that Republicans are the party of
the rich the dirty little secret is too
rich to just fine with big government